john maxwell is a pastor and an author
who's written more than 100 books and is
also named the number one
leadership expert in the world by inc
magazine he went from serving as a
pastor of a small church in ohio to
becoming an
expert at leadership and a best-selling
author who sold more than 30 million
bucks
need motivation what's your top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
all my life
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best john maxwell and my take on his top
10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one know your strengths
one day i realized that when you counsel
people you work on their weaknesses
and when you equip people you work on
their strengths
and the moment i went from working on
weaknesses to working on strengths i
became
i i was i was a rock star with with
strings because
you showed me your strength and i'm
going to give you a game plan let's get
going because i'm a natural equipper
not a natural counselor nothing wrong
with counseling it's just not my gift
you're with me and and and what did they
teach me in college they had taught me
how to administrate
yeah so i'm in my you know i've got my
little country church i'm doing
administration well there's no return
there i mean my gosh
and then one day i'm waking up and i'm
saying wait a minute this isn't working
i got to go get me some volunteers to do
this administration
so i can get back and so it's trial and
error and sometimes i think we go to
people like i mean ed
if i'm trying to find out my strengths
and you and i know each other really
well i may come to you and say
okay talk to him you know what do i do
well yes you know
sometimes we don't understand our own
strengths and it takes somebody that
really
is a good friend that knows as well that
can say well i think you're really good
in this area
but you gotta find them yeah and and the
good news is everybody
has gifts rule number two maximize your
time
when you manage something you do so to
keep it going
well you don't need to keep time going
you don't need to watch it you can be
completely aware well unaware of it you
can go to sleep doesn't matter
time just continually moves it doesn't
need you it doesn't need me
it just keeps moving we don't need to do
time management because there's nothing
to manage it's automatic it continually
moves
what we need to do is priority
management
with the time that is continually
slipping away from us
we need to manage our priorities to
maximize
the time we have so don't
manage your time maximize your time
how by doing the things that are the
most important to do
at that moment make every day
your masterpiece rule number three build
credibility
if you can make things happen for
yourself
you now have the credibility to make
things happen for other people
if if if i'm not successful there is no
appeal for you to follow me
i tell people all the time success is
the credibility
of a leader to lead because you think
about it no one ever got you know nobody
ever said oh my gosh you know okay
i gotta i'm i'm financially in deep
weeds oh my gosh i'm gonna i'm
i think i'm gonna go call my buddy joey
he's been bankrupt three times you're
right right
no no you don't follow joe joe's been
bankrupt three times you've got to go
find somebody that's successful with
your money
yeah so i'm going to get into oh my gosh
my wrong way called
jack he's been divorced four times jack
help me with my marriage
you see people when they need help
the first thing they think about is who
is better than me
that i can follow and so the credibility
of a leader
as far as to lead is that they're
successful i mean if i'm successful i
say hey i'd want to join my team
well of course i mean if lebron james
was in the room right now lebron says
we're going to play a little basketball
right and and lebron says you know i'll
pick and then jon will pick
well when lebron's there you've got your
hand i'm saying lebron pick me because
you're going to win if you get lebron
and every time i'm getting ready pick
you're diving behind the chair you're
right
you don't want to be on my team you're
going to lose all my team and so what i
tell people all the time is
that the you first thing you've got to
do is you got to be you got to get good
yourself if you're
why would i ever think that i should
lead somebody
if i'm not any good at it rule number
four focus
what i discovered about focusing in on
a goal or something you want to
accomplish is
that the moment that you focus in on
what you want to do
that's when you begin to have energy to
do it
a distracted person lacks energy
and when they get to the thing they need
to be focusing in on
they don't have the energy to give but
when a person says no this is
the one thing i'm going to do and they
set their mind to it they set their eyes
on it and they
set their hand to do it all of a sudden
energy begins to fill their life
why because what you focus on what you
concentrate on what you desire to
accomplish
once your eyes are fixed on that it
begins to energize you
and you begin to see the possibility of
making it happen
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series it's free
the link to join is in the description
below i've never met a person who was
not successful that didn't have a great
amount of self-discipline within their
life
rule number five have a growth mindset i
think there are people who would be born
with
what i would call leadership leanings
they would have a
a a tendency to lean or be gifted in
that area just like
somebody's gifted in music or whatever
so i think that
that that starts it and i think i have
that but then
i i grew up in a leader's home in fact
my father
is 98 still living whoa and in fact
until two years ago was still working
full-time
and and was a terrific leader so i grew
up in a
culture and environment of leadership
and so
when i look at myself where i am today
so much of it
was caught from from not only my father
but i've had great mentors throughout my
life
in fact while we're out here in los
angeles and every time i come out here i
think of john wooden
who mentored me for the last probably 11
years of his life wow
and in fact when you when you talked
about that sometimes you win sometimes
you
learn uh he he did the forward on that
book
and he just loved the idea of of how to
get back up after after you fail
so when you look at my home background
uh the leadership experiences
that i had because a person learns to
lead by practicing leadership
and at a very early age i was practicing
leadership
and so it all comes together and then
when i began to realize everything rises
and falls on leadership
i became really intentional tom
of developing my leadership skills so i
can remember for example
i was probably i don't know maybe 26 i
heard earl nightingale say
on a tape that if you'd spend one hour a
day
every day on one subject for five years
you could become an expert on that
subject
so i said wow i want to become an expert
in leadership so for the next five years
you know i spent an hour every day
reading about leadership talking to
leaders asking leaders
questions practicing leadership but it
really was consistent and when i started
that
process i i was thinking five years earl
michael said i could become an expert in
five years okay wow actually leadership
expert hello
and and so i kept you know i was kind of
like doing countdown five years four
years three years
i'm thinking i'm cape canaveral okay but
something happened to me about halfway
through that five-year process
instead of keeping asking myself how
long will it take how long will it take
how long will it take one day i began to
realize
how i was growing as a leader and the
change that was happening within me
and i stopped asking the question how
long will it take and i started asking
the question
how far can i go and everything
changed that day i realized that
you can set goals and have five year
goals whatever
but but i i changed from a goal mindset
to a growth mindset
and the fact that if i would be
intentional in the areas of growth
that would have the return and and would
fit who i was
then i could really be successful and
help a lot of people and
and that was a kind of a shift for me
and so when i wrote my first leadership
book i thought i would write one
leadership book and i'd be done
you know i didn't think 100 books later
i'd i had to leave the
they said you've written more books than
i've ever read in my life you know what
i mean but i didn't have any
intention to write a lot of books i but
but growth
allows you to continue to expand
yourself and your world
until there's just you know so much more
that you know and
so much more that you want to share so
you know my journey has been
really one of of understanding that that
if i
every day intentionally grow the
question is just
you know how far can i go and i i don't
know that answer i'm still
i'm still growing i'm still i'm still
moving towards that finish line
rule number six find happiness within
yourself
so many times we miss happiness because
we think it's out there
and so we pursue happiness and what we
need to discover is the fact that
happiness is not
a place that you go or a status that you
attain
happiness is an inside job that when i
am content happy satisfied
pleased within myself that everybody and
everything
will bring happiness around me just as
if i'm displeased on the inside
there's nothing that will bring me
pleasure or happiness on the outside
happiness is not an outside job
it's an inside job happiness is not
something that someone brings to me or
gives to me
it's something i bring to myself and
give myself
so give yourself today the gift of
happiness it's your choice
and guess what the moment that you are
happy within
there's a whole bunch of happiness that
you're going to experience on the
outside
rule number seven ask questions in the
beginning
i couldn't find anybody to mentor me in
leadership i mean they didn't know who i
was
and so books became my mentors and then
i did something that
i just encourage everybody to do i've
done this for 40 years
is is i began to have what i call
learning lunches
and i loved it in your green room your
your statement on on
on learning i just love it but but i i
would go out i would take somebody like
you tom out
and you know i'd buy the lunch i didn't
even eat i just had questions
and and i would ask you uh leadership
questions
and and i would what are some of your
go-to leadership questions well
the the the first question is i i always
look at somebody and i ask them
you know tell me about your greatest
failure and the reason i ask that is
because i think that the character of a
person comes out of their failures
not out of their success and i think
that the
bedrock part of a foundation of
leadership is character
and you build on it and so i want to
know about you know what
tell me about a mess up in your life and
i've had so many of them i mean
when people ask me that question it's
kind of like you know which one do i
pull out
but i really like to talk to people
about their losses
because it it just really tells me a lot
about who the person really is i
i'm not sure i'm not sure success does
but i know failure so i ask that
i ask i ask one of the questions i ask
them is
who do you know that i should know and
that's led me to meet some incredible
people in my life
that somebody else opened the door that
i wouldn't have so
i just find that in asking questions in
fact i wrote a book one time good
leaders ask great questions
i just find in asking questions that's
the way that i can grow and develop
myself the best
rule number eight go with the flow we
all like to
we all like to think that we really do
flow that we kind of
move easy and we are easy and people
look at us and it's just kind of
soothing to their soul to have us around
but
to be honest with you many times we
don't flow
and when we don't it's because uh a
surprise or something that we didn't
like and
sometimes my my flow doesn't go it just
kind of
stops right where it is because there's
something happening that
it's not easy for me to move with
my father when i was young said john
it's not what happens to you that counts
it's what happens in you
you're gonna have a lot of things happen
to you that aren't good
but if your attitude and spirit is right
you can keep going you can keep
flowing so when we stop that flow in our
life it's almost always because
something rubbed us the wrong way
something surprised us we don't like
what happened
i would just encourage you to remember
my dad's advice it's not what happens to
you it's what happens in you
the moment that you choose to do the
right thing on the inside guess what
you begin to flow rule number nine find
your sweet spot
i tell people if you want to be highly
successful you've got to get into what i
call the top five percent
okay so you got a hundred people you've
got a hundred people here in your
in whatever chosen profession you've got
you've got to be in the top five
yes you've got to get there and you can
only get to the top five
if you're in your sweet spot you can't
get to the top five working on
weaknesses you can't get at the top top
five if i'm not in the area of my
giftedness so you've got to find out
what you're good at because that'll
give you if then if you're committed and
if you've got a good strategy and
all this other they've got a good team
around you then that'll allow you to get
in that top five
and once you're in that top five percent
you're in good shape you're going to do
very well and i tell
that doesn't matter what your profession
is you've got to get in the top five
percent and you can only get in the top
five percent
if you're in your position if you're in
your sweet spot if you're gifted
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is follow your own dreams when i wrote
my book put your dream to the test
one of the questions i asked to make
sure that you have a valid dream
is this question is my dream
really my dream or
is it someone else's you see most of the
time
our dream journey begins not with our
dream but with someone else's usually
our parents they
they look at us when they're very young
and and they they kind of have a little
dream for us they start planting those
seeds and we kind of go off on that
little pathway
and and pretty soon we're living maybe
their dream but not ours but there comes
a time in your life
where the dream cost and it's at that
moment
we find out whether we own it or we
borrowed it you see if i borrow the
dream from you or someone else
i won't pay that price but if it's my
dream i mean it's really
my dream then i'll pay that price
the ownership question is a great
question because it's
foundational to our success if i own it
i could achieve it
the moment i don't own it there's no way
i can ever accomplish what i want to
accomplish
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what are you going to do to take
action on it
this week when you write down what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action on something you have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan and when you share your plan
and have public accountability it raises
your chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what
is your plan to take action on it this
week
let me know put it down in the comments
below you're in the people business
you tell a really great story about how
one of your leaders had walked by a
group of people not said anything
um and you taught him you know that that
was a real miss opportunity and then
when you came in today you literally
went
to each person and introduced yourself
what is that
power of connection well i think first
of all
it's valuing people
uh you know you have a incredible
incredible work here and
every person here in this studio makes
it happen
and one is too small of a number to
achieve greatness
and and the moment that you understand
that the people that you have around you
they're you know they're either
your number one asset or to be honest
with they could be your number one
liability
but the moment that you understand that
and begin to value people
i think that is what creates the
connection
because the moment that um i think we
all know don't you tom think
don't you think you know when a person
values you and and when a person
doesn't value you and and so i think
that
giving value to people and expressing
that to them
is the common ground that builds
relationships and so
yeah when i came in the studio i wanted
to meet everybody because
you've got an incredible successful
program and i want to meet the people
who
help you be who you are
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer
on this channel i have a dedicated brand
new channel just for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there